Hey youtubers it's Charlie!
I'm recording this video from my new apartment.
I'm just happy it all didn't get smashed in
the move across town.
But Gemma Whelan was talking about coming
back for Game of Thrones Season 6, we know
they're doing some ironborn stuff, So I thought
it would be fun to do video about that.
and new round of the giveaway starts now all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video just careful
for spoilers for everything this happen on
the show so far.
Now Yara is a pretty interesting character
a lot of you know that they changed her from
the books in the books she's called Asha Greyjoyon
the show they called her Yara is just so casual
viewers wouldn't confuse her with OSHA, completely
different character that since they been filming
season six we know that they cast Euron Greyjoy,
he's coming on the show one of Yara's uncles
it looks like the show probably isn't going
to be doing sectarian her other uncle kinda
goes hand-in-hand with Yara on for more than
any other family the line of succession is
a big deal for the great joys the Seaston
Chair that balance Greyjoyrules right now
as far as we know Theon is the next in line
but he has completely jumped off the deep
end he's Rick right now so for all intents
and purposes you are a is the next in line
to succeed balance the first time we met her
on the show if Yara is feeling a little bit
hands the she explains a lot of the hardship
she endured trying to gain the respect of
the men attaining a place of power especially
in their father's eyes who as you can tell
from the way he treats the on is a total ass
hole you must make Twyin look like a really
nice guy so becomes pretty clear from early
on that Yara is a is someone who desires power
she desires leadership so were something to
happen to ballot you think that she would
get the Seaston Chair buy rights but based
on what we know about season six it seems
like the on is headed back in that direction
so what would happen if you were to show up
at the iron Islands is completely unfit to
rule right now for the other iron born might
rally behind him because the Seaston Chair
is his buy rights even though technically
Yara is a would be more fit to rule now throw
Yara on into the mix he is a much more powerful
person much more well-traveled much more respected
in the eyes of his people he could also potentially
assert his right to rule this is where we
get into Kingsmoot territory in the kingsmoot
is an ancient iron born ceremony whereby all
the long ship captains choose their next leader
is a lot like a great council in Westeros.
The Lords of Westeros can meet to decide who
gets to be the next king if they want their
development a couple great councils in history
king's mood also relatively rare but a very
big deal especially if there's a question
of succession of this is where we get into
big changes from the books season six gonna
change a lot of things from the books that
includes things in and around the iron Islands
because it seems like Stannis Baratheon is
dead and he gets tied up with Yara storyline
is certain point but that is not to be happening
in the not can it do think Terry and was also
a big part of that that there probably gets
gonna simplify what's going on with the iron
Islands but the biggest part of that will
be the question of succession like what are
they going to do with the on if he's supposed
to be the next in line to take the Seaston
Chair but he is unfit to roll even though
they haven't done a whole lot with Yara's
character on the show I feel like this would
be her season to shine a lot of people credit
game of thrones for their strong women Yara
is one of those people can actually see her
struggle to take leadership of the iron out
could be something that is very interesting
I was in the books to something very very
different see you guys can let me know like
it even if you haven't read the books do you
think that you are up for for all the stuff
that we've seen her do is capable of taking
the Seastone Chair even if it belongs to the
on technically even if he's next in line and
even if Theon is headed back to the iron Islands
what do you think that they would do I mean
are the just going to sit around and try to
figure out what to do next or they going to
turn right back around to try to attack the
North again is already so many armies brewing
in the North you have the Bolton's then you
have the north remember storyline C have the
North collectively rallying to get rid of
the Bolton's so the iron born were to try
to come back with their own interest in the
North then they will probably get smashed
the way it definitely get to be a really interesting
season for Yara a Gemma Welland the actress
said that she is she's headed back to the
area where they film a lot of the seas were
she's filled a lot of things in the past up
in Ireland so hopefully she won't just get
pushed to the side for Yara on because I know
Yara is on is a very exciting character for
a lot of different reasons with it without
getting in the books spoilers as we saw with
the dorne characters you know sometimes when
they bring new characters on the show to push
pre-existing characters to the side a little
like I felt like even even Jamie storyline
Jamie got a got pushed to the side in his
own storyline just to focus more on the Dornish
characters let me know like what do you guys
really want to see from the iron born storyline
I think we all want to see the king's mood
but that's not something that they would stretch
out over 10 episodes like that is probably
something they would accomplish within like
one or two episodes and a lot of he has a
been asking like when is the trailer going
to come one of the units are doing promotional
material they they are shooting stuff on said
people are doing interviews with the cast
we might see some pictures by the end of the
year but typically trailers don't drop till
spring HBO has a new series called Westworld
is coming so they might use that to promote
game of thrones depending on when Westworld
ends up airing they commented that back went
to Detective season one first there just because
that series proceeding game of thrones so
they they aired a lot of promos during true
detective but in related news is a whole bunch
of stuff happening like Supergirl is airing
tonight Gotham is back, to try to get videos
out for everything I might not get a Supergirl
video out till later in the week just follow
me on twitter and Facebook for updates on
one video that can oppose and I said I still
need to build my studio out just like a little
bit just to fix the sound of it is on the
little bit weird in this video just because
the recording is just a little bit empty right
now white as way for me to finish building
everything out into like a room to her video
and all that stuff you can click here for
all my game of thrones season six videos and
you can click here for last night's episode
of walking dead major major WTF the end so
be sure to be sure to watch the episode free
watch the video you so much for watching everybody
let's high five and I'll see you guys tonight